it is Friday again which means I've got
five of this week's very best stories in
gaming all ready to go for you
this week Square Enix announced today as
X mankind divided which will be coming
to PC ps4 and Xbox one the action game
is a follow up to human Revolution and
will be set in 2029 it features the same
protagonist Adam Jensen and will
continue on the story of the last game
Square Enix had pledged to get mankind
divided looking as good as possible by
adding DirectX 12 support in addition to
AMD press effects tech the game is built
on the dawn engine and you can check out
the CG announcements trailer on GameSpot
I can't play video loss to this week for
Halo online in addition to a mug that
would let the game be played outside of
Russia the region is currently exclusive
to the free-to-play game has attracted
quite a bit of global attention which
spawned the creation of a modding
project called el Dorito which would let
gamers play a halo online from any
country in the world
Microsoft aren't really on board with
that plan though and have filed a
copyright notice to have some water
taken down as is the way of the internet
though the team working on the mod
aren't deterred by the takedown and
claim that making a free game available
across the globe is course a noble cause
the group have published a six-minute
gameplay video from halo online so you
can check out all the bits and pieces
which are hidden behind a paywall
this weekend deals news if you want a
really cheap xbox one I've got you
sorted well games stop heavy sordid but
I'll be doing the explaining game stop
are currently offering gamers the chance
to trade in their 120 gigabyte or
greater ps3 or their 250 gigabyte or
greater Xbox 360 to get a hundred and
twenty-five bucks of in-store credit to
would and Xbox one that means you'll be
able to get Microsoft's fancy new
console for just two hundred and
twenty-five bucks the promotion has been
running since April 6 and will end on
April 25 dan shop recently entered a
similar promotion which drastically
lowered the price of ps4 with a valid
trade in close all and he's a Googler
understanding the Internet's their
newest plan is to introduce an ad-free
subscription service for youtube the
monthly service doesn't have a price tag
yet that has been spurred on due to the
success of the YouTube music key beta
which lets people pay 10 bucks a month
for access to google play library and
add free music videos on youtube google
have said they've seen more than 2
million installations in a month
obviously the issue here is that many
people who despise as are already
getting ad free YouTube for the low low
price of free thanks to adblock browser
extensions but youtuber Wilson said
they'll pay the content creator partners
55 percent of the turtleneck revenues
but they determined to be attributable
to reuses monthly views for watch time
finally blood-borne exploits have been
the talk of the town and this
unintentional exploit seems to take the
games difficulty down our whole bunch of
notches use this one or don'ts depending
on how you like your blood-borne but the
accidental easy mode itself is pretty
interesting it turns out that one can
manipulate the game's dynamic difficulty
by taking advantage of how blood-borne
incorporates your time spent in the game
assuming that you're still in that area
because you suck and keep dying
blood-borne scaled down the brutal
difficulty to try and help you throw
without you knowing it I read it user
discovered that leaving his ps4 on all
night with blood-borne running resulted
in far easier boss encounters in this
case the boss ligarius would opt for his
less devastating attack and what appears
to be a less agile combat state the user
explains that ligarius had quote
transformed from an intense spell
casting maniac into a senile old man who
did nothing but attack with his scythe
over and over let me know down in the
comments if you're a fan of exploits or
if you think using them for infamously
difficult games like blood-borne it's
kinda the same as going to McDonald's to
buy a salad this week you should
definitely check out all the reasons you
should ignore released a hype on the
ships see her one out game of the month
for March and Skyrim mods features and
personal animated dragon wings and some
new dates that is all I got for you this
week as always let me know what you
cared about have yourselves a great
weekend and I'll catch you again on
Monday